-Guys, it is time
for "Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing
every week
where I send out a hashtag,
and we ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So, since the Oscars
are this Sunday,
I sent out the hashtag
"#BadMovieSequels."
I asked you to share the worst
ideas for a movie sequel.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love it.
We really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Now, I thought I'd like to share
some of my favorite
bad movie sequels responses
from you guys.
This first's from @kkattoonzes.
They say...
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Flip the script.
-Yeah, gotta do it.
-This next one's
from @igorsirene88.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @rfwiesner.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh.
-Too real.
-Too real on that one.
-Too close to the bone.
-This one's from @BakeRoss1988.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
"Call an Uber.
What do I got to do?
Get me home."
That's a good one.
This is one's from
@bradgurdlinger.
He says...
So that's...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Too real.
-Too real.
Again, too close to the bone.
-Too close to the bone.
-Yeah.
-This one's from @pose2pose.
-Ooh, nice.
-Pose2Pose A.P.
-Unh.
-Pose-2-Pose-A.P.
♪♪
-Pose.
-Makes me want to start
a conga line.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I can't -- I can't --
[ Conga music plays ]
We can't go in the audience.
-I know.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-I don't think there's rules.
United Airlines.
[ Laughter ]
-You could be Spirit for a day.
-I can?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Conga music plays ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
♪♪
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was great.
-[ Laughs ]
Now you gotta read the card.
-That felt good.
[ Laughter ]
I haven't been up there in
almost three years.
-Haven't been up there
in so long.
I can't remember last time
you went there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-One-man conga.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
A con-go, congo.
-It says @pose2poseAP.
He says...
-Oh, there you go.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Babalu ♪
-Whew!
-Oh, you should've
been doing "Babalu"
when you were doing
the conga line.
-What's that?
-You should've been doing
"Babalu" when you were doing
the conga line.
-♪ Babalu ♪
Yeah.
[ Breathes deeply ]
-You okay?
[ Laughter ]
-Let the heart settle down
a little bit.
-Yeah, you gotta settle it down.
-The heart pumping.
-Yeah.
-Get my cardio in.
-Yeah, get your --
-Should've got my --
I know.
I should have brought my Fitbit.
[ Laughter ]
-Where's your Fitbit?
-How many steps
do you think that was?
-I think it was probably 10,000.
[ Laughter ]
If I'm home alone,
I get a lot of steps.
-Now, do you -- you get --
Yeah, when it's --
You put it on your left hand,
and --
-It's like, normal day --
-How many steps?
-Probably 1,500.
-And then you put it on your
right hand, how many steps?
-Like 38,000.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, you wouldn't think
I'd be so active.
You know what I mean?
I stay in my room a lot.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-One-man conga line.
-Next one is from at --
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Dude...
[ Laughter ]
♪ Bah bah bah bah, bah bah ♪
[ Laughing ]
Stop that -- Stop, stop.
Fellas, don't play that.
Don't play that, please.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo!
-Next one's from @journeys --
@JurneesRainbow.
-Oh, sweet.
-She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow.
-This last one's from
@theandytracy.
He says...
There you have it everybody!
-Oh!
-Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Check out more of our favorites.
Go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.